Seoul, South Korea.
On immediate glance you'll probably notice
that shopping and dining are two of Seoul's
most prominent features, but after a little
more research and wandering around, you'll
notice that there's a rich history, mountains
and parks, countless neighborhoods, and an
interesting Korean culture.
The list of attractions in Seoul could go
on and on, that's why instead of trying to
tackle the entire city, I'd limit this list
to just twenty five of the coolest things
to do.
This is an overview that includes a little
history, a little shopping, food and eating,
and everything entertaining.
If you want to add something, to this list,
please feel free to leave a comment below.
Number one is the Gyeongbukgung Palace, originally
constructed at the end of the fourteenth century,
during the Jeonsong dynasty.
And I just got my ticket, three thousand won
which is about three US dollars.
The coolest part about this palace are these
giant earthenware clay pots, and they were
used once back in the day to store the chili
pastes, the soy bean, the fermented soy beans,
maybe even kim chi.
Ok, I'm at the Bukchon Hanok Village, which
is a traditional Korean village, nowadays
it's quite a tourist attraction, but you just
follow this map around, and you go to a number
of different viewpoints, and lets go check
out these buildings.
The temple is one of the centers of Zen Buddhism
in Korea.
One of the coolest things about visiting the
temple was the ancient trees on the compound,
apparently over five hundred years old and
strung with brightly colored lanterns.
The Hwaseong Fortress is now a UNESCO world
heritage site, and one of South Koreas most
important historical sites.
Ok, I'm going to start the ascent up to the
fortress walls.
So, I don't know how long this will take,
but it doesn't look that high.
Korean war memorial monument right now.
It's a pretty cool place actually.
Although a communications tower, it doubles
as an observation tower as well.
Number seven is the area of Myeongdong.
Shopaholics will rejoice when they go to Myeongdong,
it's one of Seoul's busiest and most shopper
insane areas of town.
One of Seoul's most touristy areas of town
is known as Insadong, If you're looking for
Korean souvenirs to bring back, this is a
great, yet kind of expensive place to buy
things.
Coming in at number nine is the Namdaemun
Market, located in the central area of Seoul,
and it's one of the cities largest and oldest
markets.
This is Seoul in its most thrilling local
flavor.
Yet another wild shopping destination, Dongdaemun
is not really a single market, but rather
an entire area that is dedicated to shopping.
One of the international melting pots of Seoul
is Itaewon.
There are lots of international restaurants,
stores, bars and clubs.
Another popular area of Seoul is near Hongik
University, known as Hongdae for short.
Lotte Mart has to be one of the coolest grocery
stores I've ever visited.
Step inside and you'll be transported into
a world of thrilling rides and adventurous
activities.
After walking around for a while, I realized,
it's a giant green park, with not just cool
things for kids, but for just about everyone.
I got to see my first ever polar bears at
the zoo within the park.
Along the banks of the river, throughout most
of the city, is a lovely recreational area
set aside for exercising and sports.
In an effort to renew the greenness in a seemingly
endless city sprawl, in central Seoul, the
Cheonggyecheon Stream and recreational area
was created.
Namsan is located right in the middle of Seoul,
but there are also many places to hike near
the city.
Without doubt, if you like to eat, indulging
in Korean street food at the Gwangjang Market
will be one of the top things to do in Seoul.
For myself, it was probably the coolest thing
I did.
Number twenty is Seoul's Noryangjin Fisheries
Market, a bedazzling display of the finest
and freshest seafood.
The seafood is kept so fresh in water that
it's sometimes looks like you're in a pet
store instead of a food market, isn't that
awesome.
Garak Market is the biggest and craziest distribution
wholesale food market in Seoul.
Food comes to this market from around the
entire country to supply the city.
One of the finest things to do in Seoul is
to explore with your stomach.
Much of the street food in Seoul is made for
on the go eater who just have a few moments
to grab a quick snack.
The food is served piping hot and is fresh
and extremely tasty.
Deep fried items and hot dogs are popular
choices.
Korean really know how to make ice cream well,
and not just fresh ice cream, but some of
the best ice cream packages I've ever had
are sold at Korean convenience stores.
I don't think I've ever seen as many coffee
shops per block as in Seoul.
The problem is, it happens to be way watered
down, and not nearly strong enough, but the
coffee shops are still nice to sit in, and
normally include wifi.
It all eventually comes down to the food,
and Seoul, South Korea, is literally a heaven
on earth.
At number twenty five is the Korea barbecue.
Sitting at a table with your own personal
grill in front of you, ordering plates of
meat and grilling them right before your nose,
and devouring the meat along with Korean side
dishes, and leaves of lettuce and garlic,
is one of the world's most delicious ways
to feast.
During my entire visit, I was enthralled and
confused at the same time, debating what to
eat and trying to eat as much South Korean
food as possible.
So there you have twenty five exciting things
to do in Seoul.
But like I said before, this is by no means
everything there is to do in Seoul, so if
you have any other suggestions, please leave
a comment below and let me know!